PROFESSOR: So the next important
part of turbulent plume theory
that we need is the distribution
of concentration of particles
or droplets, in this
case, that are injected
with the fluid at the source.
So as we've just arrived, the
concentration C in this case,
we could have referred
to infection quanta
and infectious aerosols
relative to that leaving
the mouth, which is
we've called C_q, scales
as square root of area of the
mouth divided by alpha x where
alpha is the turbulent
entrainment
coefficient, around 0.1 or 0.15.
And that leads to a
jet which grows in size
and grows in fluctuations as
you see more and more eddies,
and eventually might
even bend due to flows
in the room or thermal
buoyancy effects.
And I'd like to talk about the
difference between short range
transmission due to really
placing yourself in this jet
and breathing that
air directly, which
is more concentrated
than the background,
and then compare that
with the transmission
in the well-mixed
room that we've
been talking about all along.
So obviously if
we're at position 0
here right at the mouth, this
is the worst case scenario.
So if we're here, let's
say we're only 1 inch
or 1 centimeter away.
And we put our mouth on top of
the other person's mouth, that
is the worst case scenario
of short range transmission.
That is, relative to
the background room,
we're getting a much
worse situation there.
But if we ask ourselves,
how much worse is it,
so we know that fd is
the dilution factor, that
is the concentration kind of
at the source relative to C
sort of at infinity and
the well-mixed room,
so let's just say far away.
Actually instead of C infinity,
I should call that C average.
Because it is the average
concentration in the room.
And we've seen that
the dilution factor
can be written as the flow
rate of the breath divided
by the sort of decay rate
of the concentration field
at the average--
at the appropriately
defined mean radius
divided by the
volume of the room.
So that is telling us how
much more concentrated
the infection quanta
or viruses are here
versus the well-mixed room
where they're really spread out.
How big is this factor?
So this factor for the Skagit
choir, which we've analyzed,
the Skagit Valley Chorale.
So that was a fairly large
room, 4.5 meter ceiling.
But it didn't have
very good ventilation.
So that's sort of
similar to smaller rooms
with better ventilation.
And in that case, this
number was 10 to the minus 3.
And in general, fd for
typical indoor spaces--
for offices,
classrooms, and homes--
is on the order of 10
to the minus 2 to the 10
to the minus 4.
So there's quite a
significant difference.
If you are right at the
point of somebody's mouth
and breathing in their
air versus being far away,
there really is
a big difference.
To put it in perspective,
we can ask ourselves, well,
how long would you have to
stay in the well-mixed room,
far away, breathing the air
to have the same exposure
and dose of infection quanta
as if you put your mouth on top
of somebody else and breathed
in one lung-full of air.
So if we just say that if we
calculate it as a timescale,
taking in the volume
of a single breath
and then dividing that by Q
breath and the dilution factor,
that is the time you
would have to spend
breathing the background air in
order to achieve the same dose.
And this quantity ends up being
for the Skagit choir that we
calculated around one hour.
So if 63 people were in
the room and 53 or so
were infected, then
that most likely
happened through the airborne
route, as we've discussed.
Because 53 people were mostly
breathing the background air
that was, perhaps, well-mixed.
On the other hand, you
also could infect 53 people
by taking turns one
at a time putting
their lips against the
other person who's infected
and just breathing in one
full lung-full of air.
Then you would get
a similar number
of people infected on the
order of an hour or two,
which is the length of time
of that choir practice.
But we know that didn't happen.
So that already tells us that
short range transmission really
can't explain what happened
in the Skagit choir.
And as we've discussed,
it has to be longer range
airborne aerosol transmission.
But how much longer range?
We can also sample at
different positions here.
So that's the absolute
worst case scenario.
So let's consider as important
numbers 3 feet and 6 feet.
So 3 feet corresponds
to 1 meter,
which is the social distancing
guideline of the World Health
Organization today.
I would also argue
that 3 or maybe 2 feet
is kind of close
to what you might
call natural social distancing.
So if you don't impose
social distancing,
most people prefer to
have a little space
bubble around them.
They don't want to be
right up against somebody
if they don't have to.
And they tend to stand
2 or 3 feet apart.
So somewhere in
here is what I would
call natural social
distancing except in cases
where you're in a crowd.
So if you're in a
nightclub or a bar
or some crowded
space where you're
starting to press
against people,
then you come closer you
might be 1 foot or 1/2 foot,
and you might start to get
closer to this worst case.
But people tend to be
about 3 feet apart.
So we can ask ourselves
what happens there.
We can also look
a little further.
The Center for Disease
Control the United States
has imposed a 6 foot rule
as we have discussed.
In fact, it's been interpreted
so strictly in the United
States that you can find floor
stickers exactly 6 feet apart
in all sorts of indoor
spaces even when
people are wearing
masks and when
we aren't sure exactly
what the flows are like.
And we can ask ourselves,
what is the sort of level
of concentration there.
It's also worth noting
that we can also
look at a negative value.
How about minus 3 feet?
Because it's important to note
that respiratory jets do not
only increase your risk relative
to the well-mixed ambient,
there must be regions where
the risk is actually lower
than the well-mixed ambient.
Because in the end,
the well-mixed solution
was obtained by mass balance.
So that means we've essentially
counted all the infection
quanta or virions in the room.
And if there is a higher
concentration here,
there must be a lower
concentration somewhere else
to account for that.
So perhaps if you're
standing behind somebody
at a reasonable
distance, you actually
have a lower concentration,
although there is still
mixing going on.
And you will be exposed
to the well-mixed room.
Which then brings me to the
way that we should really
think about the role of
short range transmission
versus long range transmission.
And that is to compare
the concentration
of the respiratory jet to
that of the well-mixed ambient
that we calculated.
That's essentially
the definition
of when there's a transition
from short range to long range
behavior.
So where will that occur?
It will typically
be somewhere here.
So there's a certain
position, which we'll call xC,
and this will be
defined by saying
that C over the initial value
is equal to the dilution factor.
So this is the point where if
I follow this orange curve,
I've just hit the
concentration that
is predicted for the background
well-mixed room, which we've
already calculated before.
So if you use our
formula for C there,
you then get a formula
for this xC, which
is the square root of the mouth
area times lambda C of r bar,
so the decay rate of
the concentration field,
the volume of the room,
and then alpha QB.
So I would argue
that this is really
the boundary which
separates long range
airborne transmission by
aerosols with short range
transmission, which also
includes aerosols by the way.
So some of these
aerosol droplets,
you definitely could be
inhaling anywhere in here.
But if you go long
range, you're only
talking about aerosol droplets.
So this is really where
the dividing line is.
And if you plug in numbers
for different settings,
you'll find this is
often larger than 6 feet.
In fact, in some
cases, many cases,
it's actually larger
than the room.
It could be tens of meters even,
because this dilution factor
can be of order a
factor 100 or even
10,000 lower concentration
in the well-mixed room
than at the person's mouth.
So you have to go pretty
far away to see it actually
drop back down.
What that means is that when
people are breathing in a room
these breaths are crossing
all over the place.
They're mixing.
And you really can't think about
a turbulent plume lasting out
to infinity because there is
another person standing here,
there's ventilation flow,
there are thermal flows.
All of the mechanisms we talked
about mixing will take this jet
and start to mix
it around the room
so it won't look like a
perfect jet all the way.
But at least this
gives us an estimate
for these closer
spaces here that's
sort of what our risk might be.
So using this concept, I'll
just mention this is typically
much bigger than 6 feet, we
could estimate how much worse
is it to be 6 feet
or 3 feet away
with yourself in a worst
case scenario perfectly
placed in a respiratory jet.
So what we're
asking here is what
if we were unlucky enough to
be right here and breathing
in for a long period of time.
So not just for a
fleeting second but you're
sitting there and
just over and over
you're just sitting
here breathing
in that person's breath.
It's not an
unreasonable situation.
You could imagine
at a meeting when
two people are
sitting at a table
or maybe they're having dinner.
Masks are off, they
are facing each other,
talking to each other.
And in fact that is
a high risk situation
in terms of this
kind of transmission.
So let's see how much
worse it actually could be.
Well, if you plug in the numbers
then using a typical mouth
area, in this case
the concentration
drops to about 6%.
In this case, the concentration
since it's what goes as 1
over distance, is more like 3%.
So it's a very
rough calculation.
But relative, and I should
say, so relative to the highest
concentration of
reaching the mouth,
the plume has been
diluted down to 6% or 3%
as you go these distances.
Notice there's not a massive
difference between 3 and 6.
And it does make a
very big difference
in terms of decisions
to reopen spaces
and how people interact,
whether you're strictly
6 feet apart or
perhaps you can be 3.
So keep in mind that
3% to 6% dilution.
But what we're really
interested in here
is now, how do these
fractions compare
with the well-mixed room.
And so for that I
actually would like
to do a different comparison
as I'd like to do C over fd.
Because fd, relative to here,
is the concentration far away.
So I want C over C_q,
I should say, over fd.
And so this also can be
written as xC over x.
So it's basically how much
farther is that crossover point
relative to where
you're standing.
That's another way
to think about it.
And this is then six to 600.
So this is the excess risk.
If you were to
stand 3 feet away,
that's the excess risk you face
from short range transmission
if you are 100% of
the time breathing
in the jet of the infected
person pointing right at you
all the time.
If you take this 6 foot rule,
it's a little bit less strong.
You have a C over
C_q divided by fd.
It is more like three to 300.
It, again, depends on
the details of the room.
But it still can be
a significant factor.
So we will come back
to thinking about how
to handle short transmission
in light of its interaction
with long range.
But let me make
one final comment
on this discussion, which is
where is this crossover point.
So notice it scales with volume.
So something you
may be wondering
is, don't we have
airborne transmission
and shortwave transmission
outdoors also.
Yes.
And that is actually covered
by the theoretic arguments
that we're making here.
Although, as I said, these
jets really can't last forever.
But we can at least
say to ourselves, what
happens as v goes to infinity.
So I like to call this
the outdoor limit.
If you apply our safety
criterion for a well-mixed room
to very big room, think of,
for example, a gymnasium
or a sports stadium,
very, very big room, then
if there's only one
infected person,
then the dilution of those
droplets in a massive space
is like being outside.
You might as well be outside.
And what you find
that is the crossover
is very far away, which means
the long range analysis is not
even helpful.
It's not even valid.
Really, it's the
short range analysis
you'd be thinking about.
Now unfortunately, the
short range analysis
depends on many
assumptions about how
people are positioned,
how they're interacting,
what are the local flow fields.
But you have to deal with
short range transmission.
And social distancing
can play a role
in how you address that threat.
But once you get to smaller
rooms and longer periods
of time then you actually
find that this xC is
on the order of the room size.
And then you really are going
to be having significant effects
of long range transmission.
And I will argue that
for most typical rooms
that we inhabit indoors, that
the long range airborne risk is
the leading order first
approximation and best
approximation.
And the short range
risk must be considered,
but it's a correction to that.